tonight I'm here to talk about uh
something uh different which was uh the
road to surum so the road to surum was
was published in
1944 so 2019 was it was its uh 75th
anniversary of that
publication and I think it's actually
aged pretty well um uh so I'm going to
tonight just introduce you to the book a
little bit talk about the context in
which it was created why did hyek decide
yeah Hayek was a a technical Economist
in the
1930s uh writing about monetary Theory
uh theory of the business cycle uh and
socialism and suddenly he does this
popular book in
1944 and it ends up being much more
popular than he than he ever could have
envisaged when he when he decided to do
it so I'll talk a little bit about how
he came to write the book uh what he was
responding to uh how it turned into uh
basically a a an iconic document for the
Cold War okay because it was published
in 1944 the war was still going on but
it really became a very important
document uh for the post-war period and
led him into a whole bunch of different
uh uh uh areas that he would probably
not have gone to into had he not written
the book um and then uh at the end we'll
have we'll have time for for a Q&A so
um for those of you who don't know much
about Hayek he was an Austrian Economist
born in Vienna in
1899 uh went to the London School of
economics in the early
1930s uh as soon as he arrived there he
got into a a debate with John Maynard
KES a a very at that time already a
famous economist not as famous as he
would become later in the 30s after
publishing uh a book called the general
theory uh but still a prominent
Economist and they had they had some
debates but soon after getting to
London it's early 1930s so it's right in
the middle of the Great
Depression and he realized that a much
more significant debate was taking place
uh and that was the debate about
socialism okay uh the the prospects for
socialism so why would people be
interested in that well first of all
he's at the London School of Economics
which was founded in
1895 by Fabian socialists okay Sydney
and uh beatric Webb uh were among the
founders and uh it was a school
dedicated to studying economics topics
the Socialists were quite confident in
the truth of socialism so they would
hire the best economists that they could
find they didn't have to be people who
were ideologically similar uh Lionel
Robbins was one of the people that they
hired and he was a a good liberal
Economist just like hi was um Hayek gave
some lectures in the early 1930s uh he
wowed the people with the with his
lectures uh and they invited him to be
first a visiting professor and then uh
uh a u a name chair after one year they
gave him a a chair um so it wasn't
excuse
me it was a place where there was um
active debate about the merits of
socialism at the time indeed I looked
back in some of the of the uh uh guides
to the classes that were published back
then and if you were a student in the
summer of
1937 you could take High ex problems of
a collectivist economy from 5 to 6 p.m.
on Thursday nights and then walk into
Evan durban's economic planning and
theory and practice uh from uh uh 6 uh 6
to 7 so you could get two hours one
person saying why socialism can't work
the other person's saying how to do it
uh so it was really quite a vibrant
place to to be uh engaged so people who
know that background would think well
Hayek wrote the road to serfdom because
of this debate that's taking place in
the 1930s at the LSC and that was
partially true uh but really the debate
that took place at the LSC was at a very
high level uh these are people who are
building the Socialists building models
of how a socialist economy is supposed
to work and Hayek is offering criticisms
it wasn't really that that stimulated
his interest in in publishing something
uh uh like the road to serom um it was
more the popular view that socialism was
the way forward given the circumstances
of the world at the time so remember
it's the Great Depression it appeared
that capitalism has simply failed okay
it wasn't working anymore um on the
other hand if you looked to Europe you
saw these various
experiments many of them looking pretty
unsavory okay so you have fascism
emerging in in the Iberian Peninsula in
Italy and later in Germany and you have
communism in the Soviet Union so you
have totalitarian and authoritarian
sorts of of setups that are on offer and
capitalism looked like it failed so the
British
intelligencia and popular opinion in
Britain in the
30s favored socialism at that time it
was viewed as the middle way capitalism
had failed you don't want these
authoritarian or totalitarian approaches
this seems to be the reasonable way to
go anyway that was the view of the
intelligencia they also there was a
popular view in place that fascism um
was well think of of the the German
variety okay it's national
socialism okay that's what Nazism is
national
socialism but the view at the time uh
among the intelligencia that Hayek ran
into at LSC was that uh that fascism was
really uh not
socialism but somehow affiliated with
capitalism uh the Marxist view was that
um capitalism was doomed to fail
uh it would fail uh most dramatically
after business cycles of increasing
intensity and duration so the Great
Depression seemed to fit that bill so
it's supposed to fail but according to
this argument um the fascists came along
and tried to preserve capitalism from
the ultimate socialist Revolution that
would occur and there were some some
evidence some arguments that could be
made along these lines uh Hitler when he
came to
power uh certainly had the backing of
some uh some of the firms and cartels
that were existing then in Germany and
in addition uh he went very quickly
against the Socialist and communist this
is one of his I mean this is what he was
famous for going after them so Hayek
looked at this and said well this this
does not look like a very good argument
to me but he had heard it being uh U
talked about by the director of the
London School of Economics William
beverage Lord beverage so he wrote a
memo to beverage and by the way um I'm
I'm the I'm the general editor of hak's
collected works and there is a collected
works version of the road to surum and
it has the text of the road to surum but
it also has uh documents that would be
important in the in the creation of the
road to surum so this beverage memo a
memo that he wrote privately to Lord
beverage is in the appendix and and he
said there well I I disagree with this
argument that that fascism is is a just
another uh capitalist reaction the last
dying gas of capitalism is what produced
the fascist reaction and in the memo he
he pointed out that national socialism
was in fact a variety of socialism not a
capitalist reaction to it um and in
their antagonism uh to liberalism in
their proposed interventions in the
economy as well as the fact that certain
of the Nazi leadership in fact had been
socialists in their earlier days were
all Arguments for why this is in fact
something that was antithetical to
liberalism now this is not an argument
that is today viewed as at all
controversial uh you Nazism is kind of
the opposite of of of of liberalism of
the sort that that hyek is is endorsing
but at the time it was viewed as a
really reactionary view I mean if your
if your mindset is that socialism is
this middle way that will lead us
forward to a to a better Society the
notion that it is in any way associated
with fascism was something that was uh
that would have been viewed with horror
by the British intelligen now Hayek is
just giving this memo to beverage he's
not uh he's this is not a speech he's
giving somewhere um but he could see the
reaction uh that he got when he gave his
inaugural lecture at the London School
of economics in that lecture he was just
mild mildly critical of socialism and
said we're going to have be having some
research in the future that will show
some of the problems with a with the
Socialist setup and he said the next day
one of the students came in and said uh
to him and he said this cheeky student
came in and said well you've totally
discredited yourself among all of the
all the student body by coming out with
a with with a statement that you that
you had problems with socialism so it
was it was a very I'm I'm telling you
this in part just to give you a sense of
how different the world was at this
specific moment in time unfortunately it
only got worse okay it only got worse as
the 30s went along more and more people
were saying planning is the way of the
future uh we yeah the Anarchy of the
marketplace needs to be replaced by by
rational economic planning and it wasn't
just um socialist economists there were
a group of uh uh scientists natural
scientists uh hyek refers to them as the
men of science
because they refer to themselves as the
men of science we're doing real science
here uh people and they were saying no
that if you look at the Soviet Union
their model at this time was the Soviet
Union they said look like and they took
trips there the Soviets had had uh
brought various intellectuals over and
said yeah we gave great support to
science but this is the way of the
future under under capitalism there's
not enough money left over for for
scientific research but if we were able
ble to have that kind of support that
the like the Soviets give would be able
to solve these problems of the great uh
depression would be able to have plenty
of food shelter all the other things
that are necessary for for a good life
so this was the environment that he was
he was working
in so did he then write the road to
surum no he's fredri kayak okay this is
a person who is trained in this uh
central European tradition so what is
going to do he's going to write a TW
volume work that he started work on okay
it's called the abuse and decline of
reason and the first volume would be an
historical study of where things went
wrong over the past 100 years and the
second volume would be where he would
talk about the implications for the 20th
century and that volume would be some of
the ideas that he had for the road to
serf him that was his ultimate plan plan
and and what he was trying to do with
the historical part I'll just I'll give
you a quick uh overview of that it he he
his his argument was starting back
around after the French Revolution in
France you had a set of views that
linked socialist
ideas with
science okay and that the idea that you
could just like natural scientists had
conquered the natural world so
scientists emphasizing the science part
would be able to plan a society just
like an engineer is able to construct a
bridge and if we link
socialism and scientism which was his
word for it together we'll be able to
have a much better Society in the future
this is the way forward and what Hayek
did in the what he wanted to do in the
historical bit was to say how these
ideas spread from France to Germany to
England to the United States in each
country with very different sorts of
people advocating them okay um in in
Germany it was in fact a conservative uh
imperialists the German historical
school but if you get to the the United
Kingdom to England you have uh Fabian
socialists you have the progressives uh
who were not socialists but they were in
the United States the technocracy
movement in the United States so various
groups different from each other but all
have this faith in that socialist ideas
in general and uh and science uh can be
used together uh to recreate a more just
Society so he wanted to critique that in
this big book but right at the beginning
of the war he starts to realize that he
needs to do something more popular he
actually sends a a message to one of his
friends from Vienna uh Fritz mckop where
he says at the moment I'm mainly
concerned with an enlarged and more
popular exposition of the themes of my
earlier work which of if I finish it
might come out as a six pence penguin
volume which would be like a paperback
Volume so the change of the plans well
he started to be worried not so much
about the current
situation um but about what would happen
after the war he he wrote a a letter to
Jacob Viner a professor at the
University of Chicago that he knew well
and he said I'm I'm fairly optimistic
about the the prospects for the war but
no means so about the peace or rather
about the economic regime that will
follow the war he was worried that the
planning that necessarily takes
place of the economy during a wartime
economy would be extended
on okay he was worried that that kind of
central planning would be continued and
there was a number of people who gave
him pause about this so I mentioned
before the men of science I'm going to
read just a couple of of statements by
people that were the lead writers in
nature magazine so this is a a natural
Science magazine it's like Scientific
American for Britain um and uh they have
a lead writer so they have an editorial
it's published every couple of weeks
immediately after Dunkirk okay which was
a almost a complete disaster it ended up
being
uh that that lots of British soldiers
were saved but it it didn't look that
way immediately afterwards there was a
lead article called scientific method in
administration here's a line from it it
has become a matter of life and death
that the habits and customs of a la Fair
Society should be abandoned and the
economic and social implications of
Modern Life be fully
recognized